compare las expresiones en ambos lados
del signo de integración siete millares
más nueve centenas más siete unidades
signo de interrogación 7.970 elige el
signo correcto para reemplazar el signo
de interrogación mayor que menor que o
igual
comencemos por entender qué cantidad es
la que nos están expresando aquí con
palabras estos siete millares 9 centenas
y siete unidades 7 millares son siete
mil más nueve centenas es 900
siete unidades aquí no tenemos de sales
esto es lo mismo que tener siete mil 907
ahora lo que nos dicen aquí es que
tenemos siete millares siete mil tenemos
siete mil
+ 9 centenas son 900 900
y 70 que son siete de seis más setenta
no tenemos unidades aquí esto es lo
mismo que tener siete mil novecientos
setenta comparando cada número según su
valor posicional vemos que tenemos siete
mil en ambos lados también tenemos 900
en ambos lados pero en la izquierda no
tenemos escenas sólo unidades y a la
derecha tenemos decenas pero no de
unidades
evidentemente 70 es mayor que 7 por lo
que el número de la derecha es más
grande que el de la izquierda
vamos a usar este recordemos que estos
signos mayor que o menor que el piquito
siempre va a generar la cantidad más
pequeña esta es la cantidad más pequeña
por lo que el piquito va a ir de este
lado y esta parte abierta más grande se
va a señalar al número más grande por lo
que es menor que 7 mil 907 es menor que
7 1970 este símbolo va a reemplazar
nuestro signo de interrogación aquí
vamos a tener menor
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo